as fall breaks out in canada
i'm reminded of all the beauty innocence
and gun-free fun available from our
neighbors to the north
[Music]
[Applause]
there's the majesty of toronto
[Applause]
vast hockey rinks
[Applause]
and gallons of maple syrup that you can
chug openly
and kilt free for this maple syrup is
pure
and nourishing
[Applause]
the changing of the seasons also happens
to be the perfect time
to encounter one of canada's most prized
creatures
the artificial intelligence nerd
[Music]
not too long ago these beings were rare
and hidden away
in university dungeons but today
they're among the best paid
professionals in the world
together these creatures did something
truly remarkable
without anyone paying much notice they
gave birth to an ai revolution
they turned canada yes canada
into one of the great a.i superpowers
this is the story of how all this came
to be
it's the story of one nation's quest to
teach computers to think like humans
it's the story of what this science
experiment will mean
for all our lives and for the future
of the human species
so if you're a human or something try to
imitate one
you'll want to pay attention
ah
ever since people first came up with the
idea of computers
they've dreamed of imbuing them with
artificial intelligence
i am a smart fellow
as i have a very fine
brain that's the most remarkable thing
i've ever seen
ai is just a computer that is able to
mimic or simulate uh human thought or
human
behavior within that there's a subset
called machine learning that's now
the underpinning of what is most
exciting about ai
by allowing computers to learn how to
solve problems on their own
machine learning has made a series of
breakthroughs that once seemed nearly
impossible
it's the reason computers can understand
your voice
spot a friend's face in a photo and
steer a car
and it's the reason people are actively
talking about the arrival
of human-like ai and whether that would
be a good thing
or a horrific end-of-day's thing
many people made this moment possible
but one figure
towers above the rest i've come to the
university of toronto
to see the man they call the godfather
of modern artificial intelligence
jeff hinton
because of a back condition jeff hinton
hasn't been able to sit down
for more than 12 years i hate standing
i'd much rather sit down but if i sit
down i have a disc that comes out
sorry well at least now standing desks
are fashionable and yeah but i was ahead
i was standing where i was standing when
they weren't fashionable
since he can't sit in the car or on a
bus
hinton walks everywhere
the walk says a lot about hinton and his
resolve
for nearly 40 years hinton has been
trying to get computers
to learn like people do a quest almost
everyone thought was crazy or at least
hopeless
right up until the moment it
revolutionized the field
google thinks this is the future of the
company amazon thinks the future company
apple thinks it's a fusion company my
own department thinks this stuff's
probably nonsense and we shouldn't be
doing any more
so i took everybody into it except my
own department
chef hinton pretty early on became
obsessed with this
idea of figuring out how the mind works
he started off getting into physiology
the anatomy of how the brain worked
then he got into psychology and then
finally
he settled on more of a computer science
approach to modeling the brain
and got into artificial intelligence
my feeling is if you want to understand
a really complicated device
like a brain you should build one i mean
you could look at cars and you could
think you could understand cars when you
try and build a car
you suddenly discover that there's this
stuff that has to go under the hood
otherwise it doesn't work yeah
[Music]
as jeff was starting to think about
these ideas he got inspired by some ai
researchers across the pond specifically
this guy
frank rosenblatt rosenblatt
in the late 1950s developed what he
called a perceptron and
it was a neural network a computing
system that would mimic
the brain the
basic idea is a collection of small
units called neurons
these are little computing units but
they're actually modeled on the way that
the human brain does its computation
they take incoming data like we do from
our senses and they actually learn
so the neural net can learn to make
decisions over time
rosenblatt's hope was that you could
feed a neural network a bunch of data
like pictures of men and women and it
would eventually learn
how to tell them apart just like humans
do
there was just one problem it didn't
work very well
rosenblatt his neural network was a
single layer
of neurons and it was limited in what it
could do extremely limited and
a colleague of his wrote a book in the
late 60s
that showed these limitations
and it kind of put the whole area of
research into a deep freeze
for a good 10 years no one wanted to
work in this area they were sure
it would never work well
almost no one it was just obvious to me
that it was the right way to go
the brain's a big neural network and so
it has to be that stuff like this can
work
because it works in our brains there's
just never any doubt about that
and what do you think it was inside of
you that
kept you wanting to pursue this when
everyone else was giving up just that
you thought it was the right
direction to go no that everyone else
was wrong okay
[Laughter]
hinton decides he's got an idea of how
these neural nets
might work and he's going to pursue it
no matter what
for a little while he's bouncing around
research institutions in the u.s
he kind of gets fed up that most of them
are funded by the defense department and
he starts looking for somewhere else he
can go
he suddenly hears that canada might be
interested in funding
artificial intelligence and that was
very attractive
that i could go off to this civilized
town and just get on with it
so i came to the university of toronto
and then in the mid 80s we discovered
how to make more complicated neural nets
so they could solve those problems that
the simple ones couldn't solve
he and his collaborators developed a
multi-layered neural network a deep
neural network and this
started to work in a lot of ways but
again they hit a ceiling
through the 90s into the 2000s jeff was
one
of only a handful of people on the
planet who are still pursuing this
technology
he would show up at academic conferences
and be banished
to the back rooms he was treated as
really like a pariah but jeff was
consumed by this and couldn't stop
he just kept pursuing the idea that
computers could learn
until about 2006 when the world catches
up
to hinton's ideas
[Music]
computers were down a lot faster and now
it's behaving like i thought it would
behave in the mid 80s
it's solving everything the arrival of
super fast chips
and the massive amounts of data produced
on the internet
gave hinton's algorithms a magical boost
suddenly computers could identify what
was in an image
then they could recognize speech and
translate from one language to another
by 2012 words like neural nets and
machine learning were popping up on the
front page of the new york times
next up we have professor jeffrey hinton
of the university of toronto
for hinton this is obviously a really
redemptive moment
now he's basically a technology
celebrity
and for canada it's the country's moment
as well
they have more ai researchers than just
about any other place
on the planet and the quest now is to
see what these guys can do
starting companies and pushing the
technology forward
i'm gonna set out on a journey across
canada to see
the best in canadian ai technology
and to get a feel for how far the
technology has come
and how far it still has to go
[Music]
here is a city that gets right at the
central tension of modern life
and the unfolding ai revolution
[Applause]
[Music]
it's montreal a place filled with beauty
and old world charms that ask you to
move
slowly through its streets and to chill
for a while
reflect and think deep thoughts
at the same time it's one of the world's
top ai research centers
students flock here from all over the
globe to get deep with machine learning
and to take jeff hinton's ideas and
figure out how to turn them into
products we all use
to see just how successful they've been
look no further than your pocket
all this stuff started out as hardcore
computer science but over the last five
years
ai has invaded our everyday lives your
smartphone
is packed full of ai-powered apps
including something like google
translate that lets you point your phone
at a magazine that's written in french
and read it as if you were a local
engineers have been trying to get
computers to translate texts like this
for decades
but it was jeff's neural nets that
finally made it possible
thanks jeff and it's not just your
smartphone
neural networks are heading for the open
road
off we go
meet my friend stefan the head of
montreal's tesla fan club
i'm driving a tesla for a little bit
more than four and a half
do you have people asking you for rides
all the time yes
maybe that's because of his fancy pants
autopilot
tesla's semi-autonomous driving system
that kicks in when road conditions are
right
so that's it autopilot's on yes and it's
driving by itself
so we need to pay attention but
we don't have to drive yeah it's crazy
[Applause]
self-driving cars are packed full of
cameras sensors and radar
when teamed with computer vision neural
nets it's this technology that lets the
cars build a picture of the world
the technology has a long way to go but
this tesla
can monitor all the cars around it
switch lanes
and park all by itself
thanks jeff so you're living in the
future
you know when you try it once it's very
difficult
to do without it because i just can be
relaxed
and we can drive like this oops
there's a stop sign that's why we still
need to pay attention
[Music]
a big part of hinton's legacy lies
beyond these examples
of ai in the world
he's also inspired a legion of disciples
spreading the good word of neural nets
joshua bengio is a professor at the
university of montreal
he's one of the researchers who glommed
on to hinton's ideas
when it seemed to make little sense to
do so over the years
he's formed a mind meld with hinton and
together
they've come up with many of the key
concepts behind modern ai
you guys worked on this stuff through
the 80s 90s the 2000s
and then it just seemed like this
totally went
from computer science and research to
we see it everywhere in our lives are
you know are
even you surprised what's happened the
last five years that it really is like
sitting on all our phones and
the rate at which the progress and the
industrial products have been coming out
is totally something we didn't expect
even now it's hard to predict where are
we going is it going to
slow down
[Music]
or are we going to continue with this
exponential increase
[Music]
it's thanks to yahshua that montreal is
full of top-notch
ai graduate talent this in turn has
brought tech giants like google and
facebook to town
along with their ample checkbooks
to me it seems like if you're good at ai
you can make two three hundred thousand
dollars a year
it's crazy to see how much these guys
get paid now
a million dollars is something quite
common as a salary
have you ever had a country offer you an
incredible money to come
set up a lab there not a country but
yeah companies
[Music]
but yahshua has rejected the lucrative
offers
of big neural net he remains committed
to the ivory towers of academia
which is a better fit for his
philosophical approach to ai
you've got guys like elon musk and
stephen hawking that sometimes paint
this
technology in a very very dark light
that it could run amok and start doing
things on its own
what do you feel when you hear people
say things like that i'm not concerned
about technology running amok
of the terminator scenario i think is
not very credible
and i also believe that if we're able to
build machines
that are as smart as us they're also
smart enough
to understand our values and to
understand our moral system and
and so act in a way that's good for us
now i think there are real concerns
which is essentially misuse of ai to
influence people's minds it's already
happening with political advertising
yeah i mean we've already
seen like the stuff from facebook so i
think we should be careful about this
and try to regulate the use of ai in
places where
it's morally wrong ethically wrong i
think we just should just ban it and
make it you know
illegal
it's comforting that joshua has these
concerns
but hop down the road from the
university in reality
or what's left of it becomes messier
this tiny room is the home to a startup
called lyrebird
it was founded by yahshua's former
students and has built an
app that can clone your voice are you
speaking about this new algorithm to
copy voices
this is huge they can make us say
anything now really anything
[Music]
one of its founders is this guy mexican
expat jose
he taught me the art of the clone so
you'll need to record yourself for a few
minutes of audio
thousands of letters danced across the
amateur author's screen
when you start to eat like this
something is the matter
you guys better quit politics and take
in washing
i don't know where that one came from
okay so create my digital voice now
creating your digital voice takes at
least one minute one minute
my god yeah so before to create some
artificial voice of someone you would
need to record yourself for
at least eight hours test your voice all
right so now i get the types of things
yeah so the moment of the truth okay
once liarbird's ai has worked its magic
after i'm done
typing oh i'm gonna spell better
any words i put into the app can be
played back in my digital
voice and here's the crazy thing
even words i never actually said in the
first place
artificial intelligence technology seems
to be advancing very quickly
should we be afraid i mean i can
definitely hear my
voice in there that's that is that's
really interesting
i just picked those words at random and
i definitely did not say
some of them and it's like flawless and
being able to sort of pick from just
about any word and manufacture it
[Music]
hello world is the best joy i have ever
seen
[Music]
this technology seems sweet
[Music]
but lends itself to all manner of
trickery
[Applause]
i've popped back to my hotel to test out
the library technology a little bit
and you can see some really obvious ways
that this could be abused
this is this is fake donald trump
talking
the united states is considering in
addition to other options topping all
trade with any country doing business
with north korea
and then you could picture somebody
taking over
your voice and creating some mayhem in
your personal life
now to really put my computer voice to
the test
i am going to call my dear sweet mother
and see if she recognizes me
hey mom hi what are you guys up to today
um well it's saturday we didn't have any
electricity early this morning and we're
just
hanging around the house i'm just
finishing up work and waiting for the
boys to get home
okay i think i'm coming down with a
virus
oh why you feel mad
i was messing around with you you were
talking to a computer i felt like i was
talking to you
it's amazing is that scary or
good it could be scary if it was
something really important
but you know is that i don't i don't
know
[Music]
it sounds like you is it yes
the real artificial intelligence weirdos
in canada
live here in edmonton
[Music]
this is a large but very very cold and
very very flat city
that is more or less in the middle of
nowhere
it's the kind of place that has a giant
butter vault
to help people survive the lean winter
months
canadians like to put the best possible
spin on how these conditions bring out
interesting traits in people ask anyone
like this guy from the edmonton tourist
center well edmonton's
uh one of those cities that isn't you
know automatically listed in the
top cities in canada in terms of size or
scale or
or notice even but it's always had a
really
neat quality to it of that western
independent spirit that you see very
much in in alberta in general
combined with a conscience and
a thoughtfulness
over at the university of alberta some
of the most
far-out ai research in the world is
taking place
the man i'm here to see is the
university's very own ai godfather
rich sutton rich is considered one of
the great revolutionary thinkers in a.i
[Music]
you are not canadian i am canadian
but not by birth no i was born in the us
but uh now i'm just canadian
okay and what brought you to canada the
politics i wanted to get away from
difficult times in the united states the
united states was invading other
countries in
2003 when i came here and i
didn't care for all that
sutton entered the field of ai in the
mid 80s and like jeff hinton and joshua
bengio
he was a big believer in neural networks
but sutton has a different idea about
how to further the technology
unlike hinton's method of feeding neural
networks reams and reams of data
and telling them what to do sutton wants
them to learn more naturally
from experience an approach called
reinforcement learning
reinforcement learning it's like when
animals do and what people do
you try several things the things that
work best you keep doing those and
things that don't work out so well you
stop doing them
and how do you teach your computer um
all you need is
all you need is a sense the computer has
to have a sense of what's good and
what's bad
and so you give it a special signal
called the reward if the reward is high
that means it's good
the reward is low that means it's bad
to see reinforcement learning in action
i found marlos
an industrious young brazilian who's
created an ai
to play his video games for him
his algorithm plays the game thousands
of times
and gradually learns from experience how
to do better
so the goal of this game is that you are
this yellow blob
and what you have to do is that you have
to get as many potions as you can
while avoiding harpies and this is like
the ai going at this for the first time
it's they i
run it for the first time so it just
bumps into things if it gets points it's
happy
if it dies it's unhappy yes
and the eye starts to figure out that
maybe what i want to do is to collect
these potions and avoid the harpies
and now we can look at ai that has ran
for five thousand games okay
and this is what it looks like
you can tell that it's smarter about its
strategy yes
then what happens if you run it 500 000
times
oh we we got to the super human
performance level
though notching a high score is the
noblest of pursuits
reinforcement learning has turned out to
have all kinds of other applications
it's behind the algorithm that
recommends movies and tv shows on
netflix and amazon
it beat the world champion go player a
feat previously thought impossible for a
computer
[Music]
soon it could read your brain waves and
determine whether you have a mental
disorder
but for sutton all that is just the
beginning
we are trying to make real intelligence
we're trying to recreate
human intelligence humans are our
example
he sees reinforcement learning as the
path to what futurists call
the singularity the moment when our ai
creations
light up and surge past human level
intelligence
[Music]
do you have a date for the singularity
or so they give you
it's a it's a quite broad probability
distribution in the median
is at 2040. 20. that means equal chance
being before or after
2040. okay the rationale goes like this
uh
by 2030 we'll have the hardware so
give guys like me another 10 years to
figure out
the algorithms yeah software to go with
the hardware
to do it it's going to be exciting where
we're going
if 2040 seems like a long time to wait
to meet a smart robot
do not fret over in the experimental
wing of the university
there are co-eds hard at work blurring
the line between humans and machines
are you human of course not but that
shouldn't keep us from chatting
case in point homegrown edmontonian
genius
corey mathewson tell me about this guy a
little bit or
yeah sure so this is blueberry
uh on blueberry i've deployed the improv
system so there's an artificial improv
system running on blueberry right now
yes that's right corey does improv
comedy
with a robot i've been doing improv
longer than i've been doing computing
science i've been doing it for 12 years
and i
thought you know there's no more natural
convergence than taking some of these
state-of-the-art systems and putting
them up on stage one day
we'll make it to the moon if this planet
is not to be our last it is the sky in
the middle of the universe
the sun the sun
the sky the moon and the universe the
sun
the sun the sky the moon i keep thinking
it was like a ventriloquist sort of this
is like a new age
that's a really good way to put a
strange twist on it
the piece that's different is that i
don't know what
it will say blueberry i i created you i
downloaded a voice into your brain so
that you could perform in front of these
people
but i do not know what i'm going to say
i don't know what you're going to say
either
to give blueberry the power of surreal
canadian improv
corey made use of some tech that should
be familiar by now
a neural network
step one he feeds the network to
dialogue from a bunch of movies
102 000 movies to be exact
all the movies every movie for a hundred
years
and that's just so we can learn language
see how
somebody responds to somebody else
that's exactly right yeah it builds kind
of a
language model step two
he uses reinforcement learning to train
the network
rewarding it when it makes sense and
punishing it
when it spits out gibberish time to put
this wannabe kid in the hall to the test
there we go start improvising
okay campers we're gonna get ready for a
real baseball game grab your gloves and
grab your baseball bats and let's get
out there
especially you franklin of course i will
not be much longer
okay okay well why aren't you ready for
the match
i do not have any more good news if i
were your boyfriend
okay come on franklin you know how i
feel about you but
you got to keep your head in the game
right now you will see if you do not
stop
here when you go what have you done it's
friday yeah
i i know huh i'll teach you what the
character of your team is going to do
oh jesus put down the bat franklin what
are you doing
you have nothing to hide that song i
i've got nothing to hide
look this is all i am okay
end up there that's great obviously some
of the responses
are a little bit weird but then it's
really funny because then as you're
going along
it did hit a couple things perfectly and
and then it's like
yeah i mean it's extra hilarious because
of course
blueberry may not be ready for its
second city audition just yet
but corey has a higher purpose making
a.i relatable
there is a fear in society of ai
so we are kind of humanizing this ai
we're
we're taking it down a peg we're saying
don't be afraid of this tech look at how
cute it is look at how kind of naive it
is
yeah yeah
isn't there a flip side to that though
then you make it cute and and then
people start to accept it and you know
then then we wake up
i mean i i don't think that will happen
in my time
the singularity may be near or
it may be not so near but if the
inhabitants of this oddly beautiful
place keep pushing the technology
they just might create something
alarmingly human-like one day
for rich sutton it's not a question of
whether we'll get there
but whether we'll be able to accept our
mechanized brethren
our society will be will be challenged
you know it's just like every time you
know our
black people people are women people
we will do the same thing with robots
eventually
uh are they allowed to own property
are they allowed to earn an income or do
they have to be owned by someone
but a robot's obviously not a person
[Laughter]
right now
for my last stop i returned to toronto
home to 2.8 million people one very tall
tower and of course the godfather
himself
inside the system there's lots of little
processes which are a little bit like
brain cells
he may be an import but jeff hinton has
done something
truly exceptional for toronto he's
turned this city into an ai mecca
where ai conferences like this one seem
to take place daily
we are enormously thankful to canadians
for inventing all this stuff
because we now use it throughout our
entire business
we have it on record that he owes that
google owes canada we are absolutely
okay
that was a mistake
the tech industry is full of people who
adore ai
and then also some famous types like
elon musk and stephen hawking
who said well that ai might be the end
of us
to consider such dystopia in the proper
light
i've come to toronto's geekiest bar
hello george to encase myself in the
steel container with george devorsky
he's a writer for gizmodo and an ai
philosopher
[Music]
well since we're in the apocalyptic bar
what is the the con case around
ai what what's what's the nastiest
scenario that everybody's
worried about unfortunately there's
there's no shortage of nasty scenarios
and
this i think this is what makes
artificial intelligence such a scary
thing is all the different ways that it
can go wrong
it can be everything from an accident
you know where we just didn't think it
through
we gave a very powerful computer
instructions to do something
we thought we explained it articulately
we thought we gave it a concrete goal
and it completely took a different path
than we thought it would in such a way
that it actually
caused some great damage i'm sure you've
heard the old paper clip example
where you're a paperclip manufacturer
and you say hey we need lots of paper
clips
and because the artificial intelligence
has so much reach and so much power it
actually starts to go about converting
all of the matter and all the molecules
on the planet into paper clips
before you know it we've now converted
the entire cosmos into paperclips
it's a crazy scenario but it's an
illustrative scenario
we can't be dismissive of the perils i
think that's
exceptionally dangerous and i don't
think it's too early to start raising
the alarm bells about it
being turned into clippy sounds awful
but fear not we'll have years to ease
into that sort of suffering
as ai steadily plucks off one job after
another
the first to go of course will likely be
the always screwed factory workers
which brings us to suzanne gildert a
budding
ai overlord and founder of robotics
startup
kindred ai
[Music]
tell me about these guys so these are
research
prototypes so they're some of the first
robots we built at kindred
we tend to work with small robots it's a
bit like
if you imagine a child growing up and it
breaks a lot of things now imagine if
the child was six feet tall
when it had the brain of a six month old
it would be
terrible terribly dangerous how many of
these robots have ever slapped you
i have been hit in the face by robots a
couple of times
suzanne seems nice enough
she makes exotic digital art
and she loves cats to the point where
she's built a robotic fleet of them for
the office
this one i believe is called pink foot
it's a quadruped robot loosely based on
a cat
anatomy although it's not a very highly
faithful representation yeah
and then when you were growing up you
would build things as well yeah that's
correct
yeah so i was really
enthralled by electronics at an early
age
i guess most little girls would be
looking at trays of beads and things and
i was looking at trays of like resistors
and capacitors and little components but
having the same kind of reaction to them
[Music]
but don't be fooled by the hobby
electronics and the cute catbots
[Music]
suzanne is a keen businesswoman
and kindred has recently embarked on its
first commercial venture
what's going on here is we have a bank
of robots that are
learning so they are continuously
running uh
picking up objects these would run all
day
all day all night
powered by a neural network these arms
can do something that's very easy for a
human
but very hard for a bot pick up objects
of different shapes
and put them down most factories still
use people to do that sort of thing
lots and lots of people today everyone's
shopping on e-commerce thousands and
thousands of different types of objects
shapes textures weights how do you pick
that
up right now it's humans you have
millions of humans in warehouses just
like picking up things and putting it
into
another location so we're teaching our
robots how to do that
what's the hard part it's figuring out
what's a belt what's a shirt
or it's just how to grasp it yeah
exactly it's very hard to pick it up
right so things will show up in any
shape right
and you've got to figure out how to pick
it up without dropping it put it in the
location
so it takes a lot of training
of that training involves of all things
humans
robot pilots who manually control the
arms
while the ai watches and learns the
finer points of grabbing
isn't there something grim about the
human training there
and yeah it's not good to take people's
jobs away
but this kind of technology coming into
the workforce should make us start
thinking
about how we're going to pay people in
the future because ai
is not just going to automate you know
manual labor jobs
it's going to automate things like
doctors and lawyers and accountants very
soon so i think there's going to be
issues there's going to be a lot of
disruption
suzanne is a realist but she's also an
optimist
in her vision of the future robots won't
be mindless competitors to humanity
they'll be full-fledged citizens like
the rest of us
one of the crazy ideas i see you talking
about was you've got a robot
and it's working in a factory and then
it's got to go
maybe it gets paid a wage and it goes to
buy lithium
ion batteries to keep it going why would
that have to
happen i mean if you're having a
physical body they will have a lot of
physical needs just like we have
[Music]
you might have to go to their repair
shop to get like a motor looked out or
something like that and they'll have to
pay someone
to do that i think they'll just be
contributing to our economy in the same
way we do
and if they have brains like us they'll
want to
explore new things they've never seen
before they'll want to learn things
they'll want to
perhaps rest so that their mind has time
to consolidate all this new information
i keep trying to picture it in my head
though so this is the robot
worker does he go home and sit on the
couch and watch
tv after work and he's i don't see why
not i probably watch
cat videos
[Laughter]
it's hard to tell sometimes if suzanne
is laughing with us
or at us
but she's not alone in her cautious
optimism for the future
i think there's always a sense that you
know technology can be either
used for good or used for bad i'm
reassured
that that canada is part of it in terms
of trying to
set us on the right path
on the whole being responsible and
thoughtful
about the power we're gaining by
research and learning is the right trend
line
and i don't think ai's automatically
doomed to some
dystopian outcome
[Music]
we're told that politicians will come up
with policies that address
massive job loss and prevent horrific
inequality between the classes
and we're told that these guys will take
so long to become human-like
that we need not be afraid for a while
[Applause]
the truth though is that we're turning
ourselves over to the unknown here
so you know fingers crossed
eventually i think we will become
the ais we will become the
intelligent machines we will understand
how things can be smart and we can
deliberately create them
so it's you might think of it as making
a new generation new kinds of people
humanity is continuing to evolve and
why wouldn't enhanced people or even
design people be the next step in
humanity
[Music]
it's really hard to predict the future
i think there's going to be all sorts of
things happen we didn't expect
[Music]
but there's one thing we can predict
this technology is going to change
everything
[Music]
goodbye goodbye goodbye
goodbye once i power you down
that's it and if you do not mind i'll
never see you again
yeah that's right
we'll end it right there it just get
deep
that was getting really deep